il y avait un suspense qui se créait
parce que, avec les tweets,
on ne contrôle pas le temps de la lecture.
Les tweets étaient assez réguliers.
Mais, quand l'histoire progresse,
normalement le lecteur contrôle la vitesse à laquelle il avance dans le texte
mais là, le New Yorker avait le contrôle
et ils envoyaient ligne après ligne...
On avait ce suspense, cette attente de la suite.
Un autre bon exemple de fiction
et de nouvelle sur Twitter :
Elliot Holt est l'auteur d'une nouvelle intitulée « Indices ».
Ça commence par ce tweet : « Le 28 novembre
à 22h13,
une femme identifiée comme Miranda Brown,
44 ans, de Brooklyn, trouva la mort
en chutant du toit d'un hôtel de Manhattan. »
Au début, c'est la voix d'Eliott
mais ensuite elle se tait
et on entend les voix d'Elsa, Margot et Simon,
des personnages créés par Elliott sur Twitter,
pour raconter cette histoire.
Une histoire à points de vue multiples
qui conduit à ce moment de 22h13
où cette femme trouve la mort.
Ces trois personnages créent une vision authentique
de plusieurs points de vue.
Un critique a qualifié l'histoire d'Eliott
de « fiction Twitter réussie », et c'est vrai.
Elle s'est emparée de cette voix,
elle avait plusieurs personnages, ça se passait en temps réel.
Ce qui est aussi intéressant, c'est que
Twitter n'était pas seulement outil de diffusion.
Twitter était aussi outil de production.
Elliott m'a dit plus tard
qu'elle a tout écrit avec ses pouces.
Elle s'est allongée sur son canapé et est passée
d'un personnage à l'autre,
elle a tweeté ligne par ligne !
Je pense que ce genre de création spontanée
de ce qui sortait de la bouche des personnages
leur a vraiment donné de l'authenticité,
mais aussi à ce format qu'elle a créé,
ces perspectives multiples d'une seule histoire, sur Twitter.
On joue avec la souplesse de l'identité en ligne,
mais ça devient encore plus intéressant
quand on interagit avec le monde réel.
Des choses comme « Invisible Obama »
ou le mème « binders full of women » [Classeurs pleins de femmes]
apparu pendant les élections de 2012,
ou encore l'univers de fan fiction autour de « A la Maison Blanche ».
Vous avez tous ces comptes Twitter,
pour chaque personnage de la série « A la Maison Blanche »,
y compris l'oiseau qui tape à la fenêtre de Josh Lyman
dans un seul épisode.
Tout ça, ce sont des reprises d'un thème.
Il y a des personnes créatives qui expérimentent
avec les limites de ce que ce média rend possible.
Voyez, un truc comme le Twitter « A la Maison Blanche »,
avec tous ces personnages de fiction
qui pénètrent le monde réel.
Ils commentent la politique,
ils s'insurgent contre le Congrès.
Souvenez-vous qu'ils sont Démocrates.
Donc, ils pénètrent le monde réel.
Ils réagissent.
Alors, si on prend la souplesse d'identité,
l'anonymat, le rapport au monde réel,
et qu'on dépasse le simple hommage ou la parodie
pour mettre ces outils au service d'une narration,
là, ça devient intéressant.
Pendant les élections à la mairie de Chicago,
il y a eu un compte parodique.
C'était « le Maire Emanuel ».
Il reprenait tout du vrai maire, Rahm Emanuel,
surtout les jurons.
Ce compte grossier
suivait le quotidien de l'élection
et commentait tout au fur et à mesure.
Il avait toutes les caractéristiques
d'un bon Twitter parodique classique...
et puis il est devenu bizarre.
Au fil du temps, on est passé du simple commentaire
à un récit de science-fiction en temps réel sur plusieurs semaines.
Le protagoniste, Rahm Emanuel,
voyage dans des dimensions parallèles le jour des élections,
et ça, ça n'est pas vraiment arrivé.
J'ai vérifié dans les journaux.
Et puis, et c'est intéressant, ça s'est fini.
D'habitude ce n'est pas ce qui arrive
à un compte Twitter parodique.
Ça s'est fini : une vraie conclusion narrative.
L'auteur, Dan Sinker, un journaliste,
était resté anonyme tout du long.
Je pense que pour Dan, il était important
d'en faire un livre
parce qu'au final, c'était un format narratif.
Et je crois que d'en faire un livre
est un signe qu'il avait créé quelque chose de nouveau
qu'il fallait transposer dans des formats plus traditionnels.
Un de mes exemples préférés,
qui se passe sur Twitter en ce moment,
est, en fait, le très absurde « Crimer Show ».
Il raconte l'histoire
d'un super-criminel et d'un détective malchanceux
qui s'affrontent dans un jargon très étrange,
avec tous les poncifs d'une émission télé.
Le créateur de « Crimer Show » a dit
qu'il s'agissait d'une parodie d'une émission britannique très populaire.
Mais, qu'est-ce que c'est bizarre !
Crimer, le super-criminel,
fait plein de trucs typiques de la télé :
il enlève tout le temps ses lunettes de soleil
ou se tourne vers la caméra...
mais tout se passe en texte.
Je pense que d'emprunter tous ces éléments à la télé
et, en plus, présenter chaque « Crimer Show »
comme un épisode, écrit E.P.P.A.S.O.D, « eppasod »,
les présenter comme des épisodes, donc,
ça crée vraiment quelque chose de nouveau.
Il y a un nouvel « eppasod » de « Crimer Show »
sur Twitter presque chaque jour
et ils sont archivés comme ça.
Je trouve que c'est une expérience intéressante sur le format.
C'est quelque chose de tout à fait nouveau qui a été créé
à partir d'une parodie de la télévision.
Dans la narration en temps réel de non-fiction,
il y a aussi beaucoup d'exemples excellents.
RealTimeWWII [2e guerre mondiale en temps réel] est un compte
qui raconte ce qui se passait le même jour il y a 60 ans
de façon très détaillée,
comme si on lisait les infos du jour.
L'auteur Teju Cole a expérimenté
plusieurs façons d'ajouter une variante littéraire
à des actualités réelles.
Dans cet exemple, il parle d'attaques de drones.
Je pense que dans ces deux exemples,
on commence à voir des façons
de raconter des histoires avec du contenu non fictionnel
qui peuvent constituer de nouvelles formes
de narration fictionnelle.
Donc, la narration en temps réel,
la confusion entre les faits et la fiction,
le monde réel et le monde numérique,
la souplesse identitaire, l'anonymat :
tous ces outils nous sont accessibles
et je pense qu'ils ne sont que des briques.
Ce sont des éléments qu'on utilise
pour créer les structures, les cadres,
sur lesquels s'appuyer dans l'exploration
de cette frontière ouverte à l'expérimentation créative.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)